the eastern and western fronts even
though they were fronts of the same war
were very different in character and a
lot of it came out of the fact of who
was fighting it and especially how big
the actual fronts were so the western
front which was generally this region
right over here was a much smaller front
than the eastern front the eastern front
was essentially this entire
this entire region
this entire region right over there and
because of that trench warfare did not
become as major of a factor on the
eastern front in fact it was fairly
useless on the eastern front if you
imagine trying to dig a bunch of
trenches so if you try to dig a bunch of
trenches trenches are huge advantage for
the defending army as long as you can
block off the entire region with
trenches so over here you can't go
around the trenches you essentially if
you want to make some ground an
attacking army has to cross the trenches
and because you have now machine guns
and the the defending soldiers could
essentially sit behind their trenches
they can essentially mow down they could
essentially mow down the attacking army
very easily and that's what caused the
western front especially after the
schlieffen plan was not able to be
executed on as quickly as possible it
turned into just a stalemate so you just
had a stalemate a hugely defensive
stalemate because both parties had their
trenches it was very it was hugely
advantageous for the defending side
on the eastern front you had this huge
front it was very hard to you couldn't
have you they didn't have enough people
to dig trenches across this entire front
and so you can imagine if you tried to
dig a trench if you tried to dig a
trench but you weren't able to cover the
entire front then the attacking army
doesn't have to storm your trench they
don't have to do that anymore they could
just they could just go around your
trench and because trench warfare was
not as significant of a factor
or or wasn't as anywhere near as much of
a factor on on the eastern front it was
a much more fluid front you had
offensives and counter offenses between
the german the germans austrians on one
side
and the russians on the other now the
other factor and this was mainly a with
russia as a variable the other factor
was just what was going on in russia so
russia had several things going for it
the main thing is it had a huge army it
had had a huge standing army even before
the war and it was able to amass even
more so it had a huge it had a huge army
but what was going against it and this
is why it eventually had to get into a
very unfavorable treaty with the central
powers near the end of the war is it had
huge internal problems
internal
and i'm not just talking about the
military i was talking about i'm talking
about the entire empire and it arguably
was due to the war due to the the
economic and the human costs of the war
but as as we enter into 1917
you first have the february revolution
czar nicholas ii has to abdicate the
throne because of because of the riots
that are going on because of the the the
unhappiness the unease with people
literally going hungry people
obviously the the morale of the troops
going down and then on top of that the
russian military even though it had a
huge army in the beginning of the war
the russian industry wasn't ready to
fully supply that army in as good of a
way as say the german army was and on
top of that it had communication
problems and it even
in the beginning phases of the eastern
front
it even had issues in terms of
coordinating its actual armies and so
what we'll see and we'll cover this in
much more depth in in a future video but
what we'll see is western front
schlieffen plan not executed as fast as
possible ends up in a stalemate this did
allow the germans to bring some of their
troops back to the eastern front to
fight the russians this goes back and
forth as we'll see but once you enter
into 1917 you have a revolution in
russia
first you have the february revolution
czar nicholas ii has to abdicate and
then in later that year you have the
bolsheviks overthrow the interim
government and you had now have
communist russia the bolsheviks were in
no mood to continue to fight the germans
the military was in no mood to continue
to fight the germans in the
austro-hungary
and austria-hungary and so they
essentially get into a treaty with them
and and and and kind of take themselves
out of the war so we'll cover that in a
little bit more detail in a future video